- I spent a week with him
and he give me 30,000 bucks.
And then he wanted me
to go to fuckin' Europe,
and my boyfriend flipped the fuck out.
He's the one who turned me out on dope.
(indistinct)
And then I had another sugar daddy
who's, I don't want to
say a big rock star,
but he's definitely a younger guy.
I don't look like...
I'm old and ugly now.
That's when I was younger,
so I always tell girls
take advantage of your
beauty when you're young.
Now I'm older, so I would tell girls:
use your beauty to your advantage,
'cause it ain't gonna last long, ya know?
To make long story short, then um,
I met these mafia guys, and
my friend ripped 'em off.
We had run away in the desert
in the middle of the night
in Vegas, because she burned 'em!
(car honks)
She fuckin'...
These are boss mobsters.
We ran and that's how I ended up in LA.
In the middle of the night she's
like, "Kitty, we gotta go!"
I'm like, "What?"
She's like, "Oh, I robbed 'em."
I said, "What are you fuckin' nuts?"
And we're hitch-hiking across
the desert in midnight.
The desert, you know, in Los
Angeles, not Los Angeles.
Uh.
There's a sister club,
and I worked it; it was
at Sherman Oaks, Playtime.
I worked at Seventh Veil in Hollywood.
I worked at fuckin' Crazy Girl La Brea,
This is when I was young.
I worked all them clubs.
Then I went back to Vegas, and worked at
uh, what's that one?
Not these new big new ones,
they experiment, right?
Not those.
- [Interviewer] I'm
sorry, the (indistinct)
- The reason that I got jobs,
I had really long hair.
I could cover my whole..
I could be naked, but like a mermaid.
I can cover my whole body with my hair,
and my hair was really long and thick.
It ain't like that now.
I had like perfect...
So anyway, so I got jobs
'cause there was this one place,
you have to be really
good to get a job there,
and for five years, the
bitches of the club,
"You'll never get a job here."
"You'll never get hired, blah blah blah."
'Cause none of them bitch...
You have to win like
three contests, anyway,
so I walked out, I was really discouraged.
Finally, after five years I went in there,
I auditioned, I got the fuckin' job!
Those bitches got so mad!
I never lost, no I did.
I admit one thing, under my belt,
every club I ever applied for,
I never got turned down
because I was really good.
- [Interviewer] You have a great body.
- I was good at what I did, ya know?
But, I'm rusty now.
Let's see, it's been, ya know,
there's a short lifespan on that career.
But I was mad at myself because
I had enough money to buy a
house by the time I was like 25,
but I fucked it up. I snorted it.
Is that sucker on?
- [Interviewer] It is.
- Oh, Hell, shit.
(laughter)
Delete, delete, delete.
To make a long story short...
- [Interviewer] Show me your
face. Show me your face.
Your hair is covering...
- No, because I look like shit.
- [Interviewer] You're beautiful!
- 'Cause I need a facial.
- [Interviewer] Let me
see your beautiful face.
- Dude, I'm a wreck.
- [Interviewer] I wanna
see your tattoo, at least.
- I'm wrecked.
- [Interviewer] Let me see.
- I don't take care...
- [Interviewer] You have a bad attitude.
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] You have a bad
attitude about your beauty.
- Yeah, because I ruined myself.
I've ruined, the drug abuse
fuckin' ruined my beauty.
- [Interviewer] You're hiding
under the hat and hair.
- I'm hiding. I'm hiding.
Right now, my self-esteem
is in the fuckin' hole.
Myself, I'm shot.
'Cause one day when I got
older, I looked in the mirror,
and I didn't recognize myself.
There's a time when you get older,
look in the mirror, I'm like,
who the fuck is that bitch in the mirror?
- [Interviewer] You
still look pretty good!
- [Kitten] At a certain
age people look at me now,
like, I freaked out, 'cause
I didn't do certain things.
I'm like, "Who is that person?"
"Who is that person?"
So, my self-esteem's shot.
- [Interviewer] So, what are you doing?
- [Kitten] To make a long story short,
I met somebody who wanted
to take care blah blah blah.
He died on me, 'cause I was retired,
and I had two boyfriends die
on me and I'm all fucked up.
I got drug abuse.
I squandered, I made a lot
of money, and it's gone, dog.
I came out here...
I already had a million
dollars when I first got to LA,
it's gone.
- [Interviewer] What are you using now?
I want to ask.
- [Kitten] You probably can figure it out.
Yeah.
I'm mad at myself, because like...
Anyway, this is too deep.
- [Interviewer] No, it's not.
- [Kitten] You got me when I,
usually I don't disclose...
I'm not open like this, but I
did way too much of something
and it just all, ya
know, filter's just bleh.
I'm pukin' on ya, I'm sorry.
You know, so then I started meeting...
I ain't gonna lie, I
would meet older guys,
and then they'd take care of me, ya know?
As I was doing that,
you know,
I learned, you know...
at first I was stubborn, I'm like,
(indistinct)
So, I learned that, yeah, I had
strippers show me the ropes,
the hustle, the game, all that shit.
Now, I know what, this is my...
I think the reason why my husband
died and this is my karma,
I deserve it.
I think this is all the bad
shit that's happening to me now,
I didn't picture my life like this.
I pictured that I was
going to get married,
grow old with a guy --
you grow old together;
go on cruises,
(mumbling)
maybe raise some grandbabies.
You know, do like how the
white picket fence, all that.
Know what?
God took all that away from me.
He died.
I had two die.
The reason why they got took away from me:
because of all the crap I did
when I was in the club scene,
all the shitty shit.
I did some shitty shit.
And so I, I probably deserve all this.
I get what's comin' to me.
(coat jingles)
I'm a secret ninja, dog.
(laughter)
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Thank
you for talking with me.
- All right, are we good?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, we're good.
- All right.